[Musique]
ce soir est l'une des batailles les plus épiques
l'histoire que nous racontons dans cette
scène de combat particulière tourne autour
du faux casse-cou durable et bullseye de kirino
quand je regardais le combat
j'ai vraiment eu du mal à me rappeler pour qui
enraciner c'est 3:  40 heures du matin, nous sommes
à l'église quelque part à Manhattan et je suis
épuisé mais je m'amuse aussi beaucoup à
battre la merde de Matt Murdock
ce qui est intéressant dans nos
séquences de combat un diable ne peut pas laisser
de distance entre eux  parce que la
cible peut utiliser tout ce qu'il peut
ramasser, le
casse-cou essaie de garder la cible
proche,
mais dans le but d'essayer également de protéger la
page Karen, il doit parfois
sacrifier le dessus Dex essaie
de prendre un peu de distance alors  vous
pouvez vous percer avec quelque chose qu'il vous
lance au visage l'équipe de cascadeurs obtient
le script et nous concevrons l'action
est un casse-cou il est un combattant de combat rapproché
alors que bullseye est plus un tireur d'élite
à ce  point dans le jeu, rencontrez Chris en
premier - mon cascadeur se connaît
très très bien, il est très conscient de ce dont je
suis capable et donc une fois qu'ils auront en quelque
sorte chorégraphié le combat et l'auront conçu,
Chris pourra identifier les
pièces que je '  Je serai capable de faire une fois de plus ce
qui était génial Charlie est incroyable à chaque
saison Charlie fait de plus en plus d'
action réelle qu'il entraîne plus dur que n'importe quel
acteur et la plupart sur des gens que je
connais c'est mon cerveau et ça ressemble à de la
bouillie mon visage ressemble à de la bouillie  Et
je pense que nous avons l'impression que c'est une pression pour faire
de la pop ah donc je te pardonne